αυτό το η πραδιά για κάποιο λόγου έχω γραμ ριστοτέλους πέρναεια ένα παιδί από αυτούς
που πουλάνετα συντή και μου λέει ν αγορά σκυραν μπροστά το δικόου με κοιτάει το
παίρνω και τα φύρνω και ένα καλό χαρζιλίκή του παιδιού και πάω σπίτι και ακού
αυτό το πράγμα δηλαδή έναρξη ερωτική για γαδοψεόπαμες κετρακουδης ακτετέλειας που υπήρχα στιγμέ σταύρο που
σκέφτηκες να άφι το λάπεις ανσταματήσιμο τραγούδιθησέα μου να τα αφήσω όλα δεν το σκεφτηκα
ποτέ ίσως επειδή αγαπάω τόσο πολί τημουσική ίσως επειδή αυδεν αφίρμεις αυτό που σε βιοπορίζει
όμως αλήθεια να προςσπαθήσων ναυρω κάτι άλλο και θαμε μιαζητείνα αυτό το άλλο είναι η
μεγάλη αγάπη που έχω για δημοσική που δε με αφησε ποτέ σεακι με σίγουρος ότιθα
το ζήσω άλλες τόσες αλλά επιστρέφουμε πάλι στην πρώτη ερώτηση ότι όλα αυτά νουν και
νομίζω ότι χρειάζεται ένα σκαλύ τέχνεις κάτι τέτοιες καταστάσεις για να δυναμόνι και ψυχικά καιμε
τώρα τητηνελένα και φάλεε λέναντρέμο τι είναι για σέναένταξι όλη ζωήμου είναι το άλλο μισό
είναι ο άνθρωπος που στατήσκολα τα εύκολαίαι πάνταδίπλαμου δική μου ίσως κάποια στιγμή απεσιοδοξία είναι
το στήριγμα ου είναι ο άνθρωπος μου είναι εμητέρα του παιδιού μου είναι πάρα πολλά
για με ένα πλέο πήρξαν δυσκολίες που πενάθαε με την έλενα ποτέ σας έκαναν πιο
δυνάτους ποτέη μόνη δυσκολία που θυμάμαι ότι ζήσαμε είναι η εποχή και προσπάθεικες τον εξοσωματικό
που ήταν επόδινο για την ίδια την έλενα όχι για μένα αυτή υπτώς η κατάθληψη
μετά ξανάδύναμη πάμε ξανάείνι πέντε έξι φορές αυτή η προσπάτει το ξαο θεώ εμείς βλέπουμε
το θετικό ότις υπόθεσης το τελι